hey guys thanks I'm here with
international master Lawrence Trent bon
vivant also works with the Fabiano kara
wanna now we know you have a favorite in
this tournament but besides Bobby who do
you like
well goal of great players here every I
mean you can't really say that with
we're lacking in choice
Magnus Maxime Alexandre I mean they were
all they're all great players lots of
excitement so yeah but you know I can't
really go for anybody else except my
Fabiana so I'm rooting for him till the
very end even if he loses first eight
games I'll be there for the ninth well
actually I won't I'll probably would
have disappeared for the ninth but
that's not gonna happen
Karianna means something completely
different than that what's the opposite
of pulling in Cara Juana then this would
be pulling a this would also be pulling
a Cara wanna what can occur we'd confuse
the terms I know you're kind of a
superstitious guy Lawrence so just don't
even go there
well speaking of father you what do you
think about its position today against
Levon and what do you think of the
opening well the opening was very slow
it was d3 Spanish I think Fabiano
probably prepared this he didn't want to
go into a Marshall gambit and lavon's
been doing well with that with black so
he's got a very slow position but
actually past few moves at his position
I think has improved drastically and I
think he's got a little edge now and
it's one of those edges that are you
know safe edge where you can just keep
on plugging away without too much risk
and if he wins it great and if it pizzas
out then no big deal so I'm quite happy
at the moment so I didn't feel about
such an amazing tournament part of the
grand test or being right here in London
as a British cosplayer yourself does it
feel great no I love it I mean I was
here at the first one seven years ago I
remember I was commentating Magnus
Carlsen was here he was only 18
and he played this amazing gaming as
Vladimir Kramnik over him remember it
very well
and then he became real champion now
it's just great I mean to have all of
these stars here in London it's just so
good for for chess for chess in England
and also there's the huge scholastic
element of the event as well we can see
here behind us chess sets all over the
place in the main lobby
kids tournaments coaching sessions loads
of side events now it's just massive
massive thanks has to go to Malcolm and
the team for putting on this event and
also people I Peter Davis for helping
you know without him this one happens so
no it's just I'm absolutely buzzing to
be back in London and and be here for
this just an amazing event
now with Fabiano carolina without giving
too much away can you tell us what makes
him special that you've never seen in
any other player cuz I know you're also
friendly with a lot of the other top
liars what do you see in him that you
haven't seen in anybody else it's an
interesting one the the great thing
about Fabiano is his style isn't easily
identifiable so you when you asked like
Carlson he's kind of got this Karpov
esque about him when you ask about
nakamura well he's kind of got this
dynamic edge with Abbey's difficult to
locate to start I think that makes him
difficult to play against on top of that
he's young full of energy and he has got
real determination to get there so very
special guy I'm very very honored to
work with him thank you a Laurence Trent
international master we just saw him in
st. Louis and it's always great to see
you